día de reuniones maratonianas hoy aquí
en bruselas en que occidente se ha
conjurado para enviar un mensaje claro
de unidad frente a vladimir putin un
mensaje de unidad que se ha querido
escenificar especialmente en una cumbre
de líderes de la otan extraordinaria en
que se ha aprobado el despliegue de
nuevos batallones en todo el flanco
oriental de la alianza también se ha
pedido a la china que utilice su poder
de persuasión frente a moscú para que
haya un verdadero alto al fuego en
ucrania tras esta reunión los líderes
del g-7 también han aprobado nuevas
sanciones en concreto se va a prohibir
que rusia pueda hacer transacciones con
oro para evitar que sorte las sanciones
hasta ahora ya aplicadas recordemos
rusia son de los países con las mayores
reservas de oro del mundo tras esta
reunión joe biden ha acudido aquí a este
difícil consejo europeo para reunirse
con los líderes europeos en que ha
querido también enviar e incidir en este
mensaje de unidad pero sobre todo en
mantener las sanciones y también las
sanciones a la energía ahora mismo una
cuestión muy divisiva entre los países
de la unión europea a la unión europea
de hecho es muy dependiente del gas y el
petróleo ruso y algunos países no tienen
claro cómo poder aplicar un embargo
porque mientras países como los bálticos
y polonia están pidiendo que haya un
embargo lo antes posible otros como por
ejemplo alemania o hungría insisten en
que esto puede tener graves
consecuencias para los ciudadanos sin
embargo los líderes también han querido
incidir en la importancia de esta unidad
especialmente porque según fuentes
europeas esto podría provocar que rusia
de lo contrario gane